[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour
federica bonjour jimmy et bonjour
béatrice baylet n'ont jamais chez caruge
bonjour à l'équipe et brew jour aux
auditeurs une première secrétaire de la
fsm la fédération socialiste de la
martinique depuis un peu plus d'un an
alors les municipales de l'an prochain
qui approche de jour en jour vont être
un peu votre baptême du feu électoral en
tant que première secrétaire de la fsm
mais alors êtes-vous d'ores et déjà en
ordre de bataille justement à la
fédération socialiste béatrice baylet
oui nous sommes déjà en ordre de
bataille comme toutes les formations
politiques
avec évidemment des temps important pour
nous dont ceux de l'étude évidemment de
nos propositions sur les municipales sur
les différentes communes sur lesquelles
nous allons nous positionner et des
organisations et des désignations qui
seront faites d'ici peu c'est quoi
l'enjeu pour vous au sein de la fsfm
avec ces municipales de l'enjeu il ya il
y a plusieurs enjeux être présent sur
certaines municipal même si nous ne
sommes pas tête de liste pouvoir
apporter en effet une vision des
territoires et de l'aménagement de
l'animation aussi de la commune
et puis
un énorme enjeu qui est celui de
regagner communes socialistes
voilà et peut-être même de ne pas en
perdre une aussi parce que eh bien quand
on parle des municipales alors on le
rappelle à la fsm en martinique c'est
une bonne centaine d'adhérents à peu
près répartis dans huit sections et
quand on parle des socialistes en
martinique on pense notamment à une
ville qui retient toute l'attention
trinité où la trinité même alors trinité
qui fut un temps et même durant une
longue période le fief socialiste de
lille
l'emblème de l'unité socialiste en
martinique voilà que se profilent deux
listes concurrentes ce cas une lutte
intestine entre le maire sortant
frédéric duval qui est toujours à la fsm
d'ailleurs nous devons pas non et non la
fsl donc c'est un dissident de la fsm et
annick charlet qui en revanche a le
soutien de la fsm peut-être c'est ça
elle leur a probablement tout cas sa
candidature à
retenu toute notre attention puisque
vous l'avez su donc ça veut dire que
c'est un secret de polichinelle il n'y a
pas de luttes intestines il ya des choix
qui ont été faits par l'équipe sortante
en l'occurrence qui ont été faits au
regard
à mon sens de préoccupation et de deux
choix personnel et de difficultés
éventuellement interpersonnelles ce qui
ne me paraît pas être des bonnes raisons
mais en tout cas puisque ce choix a été
fait nous allons partir à la bataille du
coup contre cette équipe
donc du coup il ya un risque tout de
même avec cette division interne
finalement aux socialistes de trinité il
ya un risque de peut-être de perdre la
commune donc j'ai la passion commune qui
reste je ne pense pas nous allons la
gagner
l'arganier bon vous êtes plein d'espoir
très bien dans les autres villes pour
les communes alors quelle est la
stratégie vous dites que bon il y aura
peut-être pas forcément beaucoup de
têtes de listes issues de la ffmm mai
donc voilà qu'à l'alliance est ce que
d'ailleurs celle plus ou moins forte
selon les circonstances avec eux pmn est
toujours d'actualité
la territoriale un monde ment il dit là
il n'ya pas d'attelage qui se fasse sous
des conditions floues
je réaffirme et je les fais depuis que
j'ai pris la tête de la fédération
socialiste de martinique que je suis
garante du respect des principes des
enjeux en tout cas de des enjeux que
nous avons le besoin dans notre
formation politique de relever
il s'agit en l'occurrence d'enjeux
sociaux d'enjeux environnementaux
d'enjeux sur la sécurité des ports peine
des personnes et donc les attelages ne
se feront pas sous le coup des amitiés
mais réellement des projets parce qu'il
est temps en effet en martinique que
nous n'arrivions à faire la différence
entre un catalogue de propositions qui
chaque année en tout cas à chaque
échéance électorale sont faites et pour
la plupart ne sont pas tenues
et l'intérêt aujourd'hui des populations
et des enjeux que nous avons à relever
donc toutes les fois où nos camarades
sur les territoires ont relevé au gré
des communications des échanges qu'ils
ont avec des militants parfois sans
étiquette toutes les fois où
l'engagement correspondra à ses valeurs
nous pourrons en effet partir sur une
alliance alors si si on a bien compris
entre les lignes s'il n'y a pas
d'automaticité de l'alliance avec eux de
toute façon nous en sommes sortis je
rappelle que nous en sommes sortis pour
autant encore une fois je le répète pour
ce qui concerne la fsm est ce que je
vais gg je doit garantir c'est que nos
premières alliances se fasse dans notre
grande famille de gauche alors autre
chose maintenant l'actualité c'est aussi
comment dirais-je la commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur le chlordécone
qui poursuit ses travaux notamment ses
auditions alors une délégation de cette
commission d'enquêté parlementaire s'est
rendu récemment en martinique et en
guadeloupe à a procédé à une série de
dodi sion de consultation elle avait
déjà fait auparavant dans l'hexagone est
là en ce moment même cette semaine elle
auditionne que quatre ministres 2 hier
notamment alors davantage sur le volet
de la gestion politique santé publique
des conséquences de la longue pollution
que nous avons subies bon vous adhérez
globalement à la démarche à la façon
dont se déroule cette le travail de
cette commission d enquête parlementaire
béatrice dalle et le fait qu'il y ait
déjà une enquête parlementaire est
satisfaisant c'est un premier pas et je
rappelle quand même quand nous 2018 la
fédération socialiste de martinique a
été la première à lancer une pétition
sollicitant la gratuité du test de
cordée comme la mise en place d'une
enquête parlementaire et la mise en
oeuvre d'une politique de suivi médical
des populations néanmoins évidemment jeu
je me suis fortement intéressé à la
commission et aux auditions des
ministres et l'amant fini fâché parce
que quand j'entends madame busin alors
ministre devant une fois mini de la
santé qui prétend qu'en martinique on
peut rapidement régler le problème du
corps déconne est arrivé aux héros
chlordécone en suivant les
préconisations qui nous ont été données
je rappelle encore une fois que cette
dame il y à 10 ans était à la tête d'un
institut de d'études sur la cancérologie
que c'est elle qui avait arrêté les
études de maddie prostate
d'accord je rappelle également qu'il ya
moins de deux semaines catastrophe de
rouen
il n'y a pas fallu quarante ans pour que
la ministre annonce ne suivit munich
médical des populations l'indemnisation
des agriculteurs et nous tous à cinéma
pour nous il est rappelé à mai mais on
est ou alors à propos du dépistage
gratuit du taux de chlordécone dans le
sang un pur pour les habitants de
martinique
justement là agnès buzyn la ministre de
la santé a indiqué hier lors de cette
audition par la commission d'enquêté
parlementaire que je la cite c'est est
potentiellement anxiogène et que selon
elle il valait mieux le faire dans un
cadre d'étude et de recherche parce que
le chlordécone disparaît du sang au bout
de six mois et elles privilégient donc
pour connaître plutôt des taux moyens
elle privilégie les selon collectif
disons pour connaître les taux moyens et
elle elle dit d'ailleurs que le taux
moyen donc de chlordécone dans le sens
de nos populations est en baisse depuis
dix ans avouez quand même le sait parce
que moi j'aimerais bien savoir comment
madame à l'horizon le sait nous on vient
de nous annoncer que l'ol land et
connaît un organisme indépendant a été
consulté sur ce sujet précis et devrait
remettre ses conclusions en 2011 donc un
organisme indépendant qui fait des tests
sur la population sans que la population
ne sache je ne vois pas comment madame
buzyn même si bien des études croisées
qui permettent en effet de deux de
croire que eu égard à l'alimentation
eu égard à nos nos modèles de
consommation va en effet
probablement et tout ce qu on est
probablement tous contaminés puisqu'on
était à 92 et 95 % pour la guadeloupe
mais je suis désolé lorsque vous
souffrez d'une intoxication
on vous test pour savoir votre niveau
d'intoxication alors je vous dis je suis
c'est une attitude à mon sens ce qui est
une attitude et je le dis et je pèse mes
mots passe colonialiste on traite les
martiniquais les guadeloupéens
contaminées depuis 47 ans comme des
enfants ça suffit nous sommes des gens
responsables nous participons à l'effort
national
nous souhaitons que la sécurité sociale
puisse prendre en charge le fait
d'évaluer notre taux d'intoxication à ce
produit qui est encore présent voilà et
nous souhaitons de fait qu'une politique
sanitaire soit mise en place de suivi
des populations et on suit quand on peut
faire un constat on arrive à suivre
quand on fait un constat lé nous allons
terminer
béatrice dalle est ce cela aux cadis
peut-être avec l'actualité judiciaire
ces dernières semaines ces derniers mois
qui a concerné un certain nombre d'élus
la plus récente évidemment qui a défrayé
la chronique
c'est la mise en cause par la justice
deux rodolphe désiré le maire du marin
dans l'exercice de ses fonctions
municipales
mais bon on peut citer le cas également
de athanase jeanne rose par exemple
maire de saint joseph
récemment qu'on donne condamné qui a
fait enfin pourvoir en cassation et ce
qui suspend donc sa condamnation et puis
alfred marie-jeanne on l'a appris là ces
derniers temps qui pourrait être traduit
devant le tribunal correctionnel
concernant la sphère dit green parrot
alors voilà on va mais en quelques
secondes parce que quelques secondes
écoutez je crois que oui oui il ya
heureusement des affaires bien plus
graves mais elles doivent quand même
nous interpeller parce que les
populations aujourd'hui demandent de la
transparence dans l'action politique et
je crois que à la veille des élections
municipales il va évidemment falloir
être vigilant sur ça il faut faire aussi
la différence pour moi lorsque l'on
soutient
quelqu'un que l'on considère comme un
ami et un collègue entre le soutien face
à une attaque politique qui peuvent et
qui peut être fait parce qu'il ya une
justice politique qui oeuvrent parfois
et puis les soutiens qui peuvent
paraître quand même un peu en décalé ou
en tout cas anormaux lorsque l'on
connaît les chefs d'accusation dont je
crois qu'il faut être vigilant parce que
la population est de plus en plus
attentifs l'association des maires de la
martinique a produit un communiqué de
swiss et je pense mais je pense que
c'est une erreur et je pense par
ailleurs mais ça dessert probablement
plus l'individu parce que plus on est
grand plus on est affirmé comme étant
grand et plus ben si jamais on devient
coupable
les faits qui nous sont reprochés sont
graves voilà donc on a un devoir
d'exemplarité
merci merci béatrice baylet 2 d'avoir
répondu à nos questions un bon mardi à
vous tous merci à vous revoir